розвинена всім усім доброго вечора на
сноуден і по 20 12 означає екз орди
платформою масивної петренко
міністерству квіти наука виходити в ефір
і я її модератор Володимир страшенно раді
вас псих вид від ми продовжимо а на шкоду
з веденого українцями спиртом і до
психологи диво тільки я зараз but та
продуктивним та ефективним та
гарчать і зустрічатися з бачимо ці місця
нами сьогодні ми запросили гості артема
кабелям c сертифікати аудиту
експерт із боротьби за фінансовим мошенником
100 осіб багатих на асоціацію
профільних тас безумовні по праву
картку 9 аудиторських груп у святому
добрий вечір вам артема на добрий вечір
добрий вечір усім глядачам
так владно давайте наприклад раз
починаємо їх дзеркальну рамкою у нас травня
а три місяці вже трава та вина та ціну за
весну відображається на кожному з нас
помилку там вони кінця шурупи ти куди
вбивши ти путін путін голки завтра ми
допомагаємо, а післязавтра ми проблему секс
і такі душ відривалася з програм шляху
з телефоном за раз ми вийшли на
примітивні плату cool і дає силу знаки
вже в тому ж путін і виїзд на дружина
розуміння того курка все закінчиться і c
навіть самі спливай на нашу мотивацію
nutrition ось ви у своєму бізнесі бізнесі
у своїй сфері з понад тисячу людей
менше матового не тільки зазвучати за раз
на дякую за питання дійсно
питання вигоряння питання емоційної
нестабільності вони є даний
момент
дуже важливими і якою б людина не була
сильним і так далі війна
саме емоційно торкнулася
абсолютно все від великих бізнесменів
до звичайних людей і тут абсолютно це
нормально так можу сказати те що
незважаючи на те, скільки у бізнесмена є
на рахунку і які його активи він точно
так само емоційно реагуватиме на
цю ситуацію також які люди у яких
елементарно навіть нічого немає ось тому
емоційний рівень стресу він
досить високий абсолютно все щастя
моїх клієнтів моєї команди природно
всі були м'яко кажучи в шоці коли всі
почалося те, що ми дуже швидко зробили
ми природно поєднали з командою
проговорили взагалі план дій
звичайно в той момент до речі кажучи я
був не в Україні ми були одним з
останніх рейсів які вилетіли з
україни я летів тоді на бізнес
конференцію разом з big money для тих
хто знає передплатників каналу webmoney
чи телеф казахстан тобто війна
застала фактично зненацька перша думка
про те, що рідні києві про те, що що
треба з цим щось зробити другі думки
природно що робити з командою тому
що бізнес хоч я є одним з
власників міжнародної компанії
бізнес звичайно локалізований більшості
своєму в Україні відповідно стояв
питання а як у принципі далі бути
тому що
клієнти та клієнтська база природно
вони відразу ж відреагували на
природно події тому що так чи
інакше ми є фінансовими
провайдерами фінансових та юридичних
послуг
звичайно коли почалася війна була
м'яко кажучи не раніше для нас це
переривання нашого грошового потоку ось і
відповідно опитування слава богу було
фінансової подушки вона досі є
всі ці роки ми досить так працювали
ретельно я взагалі проповідую принцип 24
на 7 речі задавайте питання у
мене червоний з собою і в Європі книга до
45 де саме таки описані там 103
мотиваційні фрази
методології читання цієї книги просто
вранці відповідаєш
прокидаєшся відкриваєш книгу це ми
зчитуємо на фразу мотиваційними то
є вона якраз таки
стане в нагоді всім тим, хто зараз перебуває
такому емоційному спустошенні вона
допомагає трошки налаштуватися на
правильний лад ось відповідати на ваш
питання
як відчували я в цілому
реакцію від бізнесменів із якими
працюю оточенні природно та таке
таке такі емоційні
флуктуаціями природно присутні але
за родом своєї діяльності роботи з
великими бізнесменами багато хто з них
зараз 3 локацію хтось у принципі
думає іменник і на західну
україну або відразу ж здійснювати в
Європу тобто досі незрозуміло але
абсолютно всі впевнені в тому, що до
жаль дана історія
потрібно абсолютно чесно сказати що на
якийсь час затягнеться ось тому
потрібно в цілому планувати своє життя
або ж в Україні або десь тих чи тих
хто може собі дозволити бути в Європі
звичайно планувати найближчим часом
залишатися там ось тому що до
жаль рішення поки ніякого не
прийнято ось і власне кажучи
так все це швидко не закінчиться
ось відповідно
емоційний стан ну крайній
мірі у мене у команди це боляче більше
ніж стабільна навіть я можу сказати
що коли воно почалося всі ми з моїми
партнерами з низки інших напрямів
створили криптовалютний фонд anche
називається і україни в рамках яких
залучили 10 мільйонів доларів від
донорів з усього світу у тому числі сам
бутерин нам відправив два з половиною
мільйона доларів зі свого особистого
акаунту відправив нам гідні мільйона
доларів в ефірі ми також ці гроші вже
практично всі роздали допомогли всім
нашим українця і досі допомагаємо
зараз у нас є кілька програм де
ми допомагаємо жінкам із дітьми йдемо
допомагаємо пенсіонерами, де ми допомагаємо
саме найбільш постраждалих регіонів
отвір харків а
ось відповідно
дана волонтерська допомога вона в тому
числі допомагає незважаючи на те, що вони в
Україна з перших не була ні про Україну
допомагає
за допомогою цієї ось таки допомоги я
можу дистанційно допомагати всім усім
нашому українському українцям ось
власне кажучи не будучи поряд ось я
вважаю частину перше перше що звичайно
ось що стосується мене тобто перше
звичайно пару тижнів були емоційно
дуже складними просто рідні були не
саме серце було не на місці або на той час
поки їх до себе не перевіз мені було
звичайно шалено складно тому що київ
підбирався бомбардуванням постійним буде
відповідно це я сфокусувався
в першу чергу на тому
що я сфокусувався на тому
перекласти своїх близьких, тому що я
зрозумів що до тих пір, поки вони не зі мною
я нормально не можу функціонувати не
можу нормально працювати тому це
таке перше коло турботи які
найважливіший паралельно ми з
партнерами зібралися з низки напрямків
просто мені не тільки аудиторської
компанії є ще ряд інших компаній
визначили яким чином ми далі
функціонуємо команди тобто як ми їх
підтримуємо такі як ми виплачуємо
заробітну плату як ми виплачуємо
бонус і процент і так далі ми з усіма
з'єдналися вирішили що моменти
урізаємо трохи бонуси вирізаємо трохи
зарплату на всьому стабільно гребель
власне кажучи вдалося в нас компанії
Європі компанії близько 700 осіб
вдалося всіх зберегти, а ось і зараз
вже більш-менш стало простіше
ось тому це друге коло турботи.
кури турбота він все одно був незважаючи на
те, що в якийсь момент рідні були не
зі мною все одно ми з колегами
намагалися допомогти, якщо пам'ятаєте цей кейс
коли людина вона їхала БМП на балоні
ми якраз йому
було б літай організація яка
допомогла зробити операції пластини і ми
всередині пластини профінансували цю
остання була його операція 7070 провели
ну ось і слава богу він уже видужав і
ходить ось тому всі хто до мене
зверталися я намагався максимально
допомагати і в тому числі фонд намагався
допомагати ось тому ми дуже внесли
великий внесок саме по
допомоги українцям та підтримка їх
психоемоційного стану
елементарно для тих, хто знаходився
знаходиться на межі виживання ми допомагали
медикаментами їжею
продовольством та
фінансували реабілітацію для тих, хто
постраждав але загалом так то нуцці теж
круто такі проекти як його місто ви на
душі вашим послугам і не здається всім
нас.
ну дрова на абсолютно всі пункти в
тиці кущиком обсі рубик і вимагатиме людей
тому ж класно дурню сказала б про
виталик бутерин атс обожнюю ведена
історія де друзів для ти хто називається
автори є знаю голосних за основних з
марією ефір катерина петрова контакт з
перших рук скажімо так і папір був
прямо на 3 а перейдемо з вами прямо
мотивація до та я думаю що та xebec менше
втомлювалися я нехай і жити авто в Україні
україні через три місяці і часто люди
нам задній випробування збуту тут я але я не
можемо вийти з такого знає і а по
1000 стану в початку бублики стилі там
ви ж ти за безсмертя bespeco і нехай
собі ради не там не знають she wandered та
за раз усі шляхи на ці в ворота крихтою
мусина тому що житиму довго і
банально душу відновити статус 2
лижі поєднуєш знайти нові начитаними
ку-сан равликів випитих продуктивної рубає
княжни ти цел і труби тэц і занепалого кроку
вид точки я лежу на дивані до точки я
рублю з продуктивно для служителя своєї
роботи бізнес учнями і тоді
так дякую за питання тут є на
насправді багато досить розгорнутий
відповідь
можу сказати що
війна мене застала ось я підійшов до війни
ось прямо на дуже таких ось високих
оборотах у мене було просто день був
просто розписані посекундно і в такому
режимі я вже жив не знаю напевно
останніх років сім коли все почалося
звичайно щоб
вийти із зони дискомфорту потрібно спочатку
до неї зайти ось я якраз цю зону
комфорту не потрапляв останні сім років
ось тому коли все почалося не знаю до
щастя це в моєму випадку це на щастя
я якраз був напевно частиною
морально готовий тому що нам не
досить велика кількість
обов'язки було багато компаній
тому я до цього моменту був
максимально мені здається підготовлений
емоційно природно
були питання як далі все
розбивати не ось але
те що я можу якими інсайтами можу з
вами поділитися але перше ось моїх її
якраз і там є таке невелике
передмова
де я говорю про те що але все що нас
оточує це енергія гроші енергія не
знаючи інформація від енергія люди ця
енергія вчинки це енергія мети цієї
енергії так далі для себе необхідно
визначити всі ті джерела енергії
які за допомогою яких ви
записуєтеся на можу поділитися своїми
наприклад спорт спорт дуже сильно
запитує енергії коли ви займаєтеся
спортом
фактично
спорту теж насправді таке
природне тобто у процесі спорту
виділяється там молочна кислота
таке природне сп'яніння викликає спорт
якщо ви займаєтеся великою
інтенсивністю і так раз таки стану
ось коли ви приходите зі спорту класно
позаймалися і вам добре.
молочна кислота на вас трішки по
розслабляє ось тому точно це спорт
це заняття спортом коли все трапилося
я
напевно, десь ну було в мене
переривання заради близько 5 днів хоча
такого ніколи не була потрібна
справді я отримав такий
емоційний удар енергетично де
потрібно було спортом вимагає природну
енергію у тому числі але він віддає багато
мені потрібно було налаштуватися, але коли я
вийшов знову ось
повернувся свій колишній стан почав по
принаймні повертатися тому що
час того коли все почалося я трошки
так мав на увазі незважаючи на те що
був готовий я це називаю від будови її
самого себе я свої вже книжку мене була
електронна версія під момент не
прочитала всі ті джерела енергії
нагадав собі якими я харчувався тому
перше джерело енергії то це спорту
завжди мене як слід, 2 чого мені не
вистачало це наших українських книг
є ось цих джерел інформації
дуже сильно запитують книги тому що
книги це така квінтесенція досвіду
інших людей придбаного на
протягом багатьох років тому читання
книг це також для мене достатньо
суттєве джерело енергії
природно улюблена робота на той момент
був дуже багато невизначеності ось як
в цілому далі я в інший бік
допомагав думав що
teka трактів які у нас є та вистачить
на якийсь час я завжди намагаюся
думати наперед ось тому
звичайно в той момент я також заком
увірував і подумав себе зібрав себе
зібрався і подумав, що потрібно не
зупинятися і робити принцип те що
виходить найкраще ось тому я пішов
у свій місцевий офіс він у нас у тому числі
знаходиться в кожній з країн Європи та
зустрівся з його фаун дарами сказав що
ось ми український ваш підрозділ
власниками українського підрозділу
давайте кооперуватися і на той момент
ми обговорили ряд до операції у тому
числі аутсорсингу в нашій команді та
змогли деяких людей перемістити для
щоб а не для того щоб їх
елементарно під завантажити відповідно
робота для мене так само джерело енергії
від джерела самореалізації як не
дивно холодні душі я люблю крижані
душі завжди приймають лише крижані
душі крижаний душ допомагає підбадьорити себе
як слід бути особливо крижаною так
щоб ваша не мали кінцівки він
допомагає тобі трохи підбадьорити її
правильно налаштуватися
тому крижані душі дуже класно
допомагали голодування небезпечне джерело
енергії я завжди зазвичай перед якимись
важливими переговорами я не їм принцип
або ж перед виступом ось сьогодні у
мене вже 3 виступи так сьогодні
склалася що сьогодні 33 виступи ось
але я маю на увазі коли ось велика
аудиторія мені на межі було
виступи у празі рамках by boni там
було б списати людина зала була
повністю який повний до речі кажучи
сьогодні, але попередньому вебінарі було
півтори тисячі людей, але коли ти взяли
природно це зовсім інша
енергія ось відповідно голодування
також живить мене енергією, тому що
організм не витрачають енергію на
перетравлення він відправляє по
принаймні у мене так трапляється
енергію повністю все на
інтелектуальний на інтелектуальний
будь-які міркування щодо цього нас
інший серед перед виступом де одну
ну от наприклад у мене був виступ
десь близько третьої години дня
Якщо у цей день просто
нічого не in the sea вранці стало просто
попив води і чого не про тих пір поки не
виступлю намагаюся щоб
між мною та аудиторія та між мною та
думками які генерують не було
ніяких посередників у вигляді їжі і так далі
ось так я влаштований я для себе таку
формулу знайшов
зрозуміло що ось як мінімум ось ці ось
джерела енергії as акумулював та
до речі можу сказати що ніщо не
бадьорить нас, бо якісь майбутні
перемоги тобто іноді можна себе таким
чином запрограмувати але або
мотивувати уявити собі ну або
уявити якусь мету ось тільки
реальну мету і вона по ідеї якщо і якщо
вона реально так вона по ідеї як
правило має живити енергією можна
взяти з майбутнього трошки енергію не
трансформувати її справжня але для
цього потрібен бути поетапний план тобто
ви повинні самі щоб сісти наодинці
конкретно проаналізувати ті ваші
сильні сторони і просто бігти не
Зупиняється дуже важливо в цьому
момент не закриватися вдома тобто потрібні
ідеї та спілкуватися з людьми тому що люди
живлять енергії під час обговорення
будь-якої теми з людьми з іншими ви
можете по-перше ви гав це у вас не
має бути синдрому хибної унікальності
проблеми абсолютно у всіх однакові
абсолютно всі емоційні переживають
просто багато людей не зізнаються що вони
переживають ці проблеми незалежно
від соціального до соціального статусу
абсолютно всі переживають проблеми просто
ми біологічні істоти, у яких є
дуже велика складова емоційно
ось тому нам і абсолютно все
хвилюємося і тут абсолютно нічого такого
ні всі відчулися а плюс мінус 1 в одній
і тієї ж ситуації природно у когось
на краще у когось на гірше на так чи
інакше багато хто був не готовий ось тому
як і тут до речі на щастя мене врятувала
врятував мій настрій, тому що я завжди
налаштовувався на те, що завтра там
почнеться або апокаліпсис або так
далі тобто була фінансова подушка а
була фінансова подушка в компанії було
розуміння того, як я зможу рік як
мінімум прожити навіть якщо взагалі нічого
не робитиму тобто я до цього
абсолютно готувався і це дуже класне
вправа, а багато хто до речі, а хто пережив
донецьк чотирнадцятому році дуже багато хто до
цьому були вже готові підготовлений
ось тому дуже важливо звичайно на
майбутнє думати про пройшла про і
програвати зробити такий самий
програвати найжахливіший варіант
щоб бути готовим якимось дуже
негативних наслідків тому
повертаючись до того, як не вибирати потрібно
визначити для себе джерела енергії
реально які вас живить енергія з
щодня день у день користуватися
цими джерелами у контексті конкретних
поставленої мети якщо ви чоловік і ви
розумієте, що у вас є хлопці сім'я
повинна бути найбільшим мотиватором у
цей час багато дверей зараз відчинені
як не дивно такий складний час
є ж час та можливості я вам
можу точно сказати чому тому що ось
зараз наприклад бізнес-середовище вона стала
більш ефективно ніхто на зустрічах не
зустрічається просто так все хоч зараз
заробляти гроші навіть якщо вони є
тому що ми не розуміємо взагалі де ми
будемо далі швидше за все там я
плюс-мінус розумієш той найближчий час
там найближчого року не планую
повертатися тому що елементарно
на жаль бізнес активність зараз
знаходиться на спаді
тому я буду розумію що годуватиму
свою команду проектами з Європи
природно ці проекти допомагатиме
всім тим хто залишився в Україні в тому
в числі це стосується іноземних
інвестицій тому що кожен із цих
проектів він заходитиме в Україну та
податки сплачені від нього падатиме
український бюджет ось тому моя місія
абсолютно забезпечити свою команду роботи
і я розумію що найближчим часом я буду
тут тому що тут є зовсім
інший порядок денний ти не думаєш що
прилетиш ти енергію свою спрямовуєш
саме на заробітки тобто ти
спрямовуєш енергію на отримання нових
проектів на їх виконання саме тому
порядок денний абсолютно інший ти не
витрачаєш енергію на думці що я для себе
ще виніс це те, що я якийсь момент
підключився від усіх цих міліграм
каналів перестав читати це ось
постійну інформацію негатив та це не
те, що я пішов від реальності природно
реальності вистачає тому, що кожен з
моїх клієнтів практично щось або ж
втратив фінансової або складські
залишки або ж склади або ж в офіс
зруйнована і так далі це все так на
порядку денному простою всі вони наближають
і негативом тому що так чи інакше все
і змі зараз завдання залучити
увага збільшити цитованість незважаючи
на те, що навіть українські засоби масової інформації
намагаються природно часто
драматизувати ту чи іншу ситуацію
ось цьому я просто заміню тіло абсолютно
ось усі канали які у мене є
залишив тільки бізнес канали які
сповіщають
економічної ситуації аналогових
якихось нововведення і так далі про
економіці всю війну я просто вимкнув
тому що вона відбирають дуже сильно
твою енергію
енергію ефективності і за підсумком ти з
поганим настроєм і спустошений тому я
дуже сильно раджу, якщо є
можливість включити всі ці канали про
війні займіться справою якщо ви чоловік
йдіть заробляєте гроші тому що
економіки потрібно дуже сильно допомога
зараз хтось іде на фронт і воює хтось
то йде і поливають так само я
інтелектуально у нас свій фонд є і
він не менш важливий
чимось як наші бійці за су обороняють
нас а на фронті на передку ось тому
тут необхідно конкретно визначитися в тому і
це питання одне яке одне з питань
який я себе сам теж поставив що я я
йду на передок борючись або ж я йду і
борючись інтелектуально на мене
вибір очевидний тому що співробітники
електронної праці всі ці роки будував у
в тому числі свою кар'єру бренд компанію та
так далі я не можу це вибачте мені
просто так відразу ж кинути а куди ж
гроші всіх тих людей, які на мене
дорівнюють ось тому мене
інтелектуальний фронт цим власне
кажучи я займаюся я думаю що якби я
сидів у окопі в києві то мені точно було
би не до криптовалютного фонду та на
допомога та інші тобто у мене б була
зовсім інший порядок денний ось
тому я вирішив що моя допомога
полягає в цьому тобто ми з
партнерами допомагаємо нашим українцям
кожен день ось я роблю абсолютно все
щоб ми в тому числі поповнювали фонд
ось тому ось такий ось мене розгортка
здивувало харчування такі що за раз у
україні душі все
призначив їх принципі давити цю ж за
які такі діалоги ще до того що
mizer би ти напружив натурі для того щоб
його в цій ситуації чи ні і шує а його
але на душі долара з точки збору гармату
роботи у від авт втратах роботи та
клієнтів і такі штуки всі ти заходиш у
Україна то людина не покаже і кайма і
видавати на божевільну
nike сфери так можна але обидва він за
зростанням з блату побуду вата бізнес при
найму на язичці бонус закускою rapid i
wait ну звичайно в першу чергу потрібно
зрозуміти щось місце робити найбільше
я думаю що варто було б
постаратися налагодити пдд онлайн це
онлайн консультація також, що я зробив я
спробував звичайно використати свій
інтелектуальний потенціал та свої зв'язки
спробувати зайнятися тим, що мені
виходить найкраще ось тому даного
у разі потрібно взагалі усвідомити
пристрій з собою такий менший нарада
і зрозуміти взагалі
що ще з чого я можу робити що
затребуване та спробувати
і спробувати за допомогою цього заробити
гроші і соціальний капітал
це такий ось я називаю що це
непорушний
нематеріальний актив який завжди
залишається з нами тому якщо є в
оточенні підприємця яким потрібна
робота
зараз допомога в роботі то дзвоніть
обдзвонювати і їм кажіть що в мене
сім'я готовий робити все, що скажете
головне щоб за це було сплачено щоб
хоча б виживати ось тому аби
було бажання
ось тому важливо звісно усвідомити свої
сторони хтось зараз ударяється у крипто
валюту але знову ж таки якщо ви ніколи не
займалися трейдингом є ризик того
щоб нормально можете програтися
тому я б не радив тим людям
які ніколи не мали стосунку
крипто валютам займатися трейдингом
найбільша дурість яку можна
зробити нічого вам не пощастить я отрута на
моє ставлення криптовалюте так якщо ви
не професійний гравець ви просто пили
криптовалюту просто чекаєте коли на
вирости продаєте її на піку потім чекаєте
спад знову закуповує все так все більше
так, тому що трейдинг закінчується
звичайні мінусами я такий досвід у тому
числа проходив був і позитивним був і
не й особливо позитивний досвід але волосінь
я знайшов таку формулу тому не
надумайте останні гроші засовувати
криптовалюту грати батур років
ось тому зараз дуже багато відкрилася
безкоштовних курсів онлайн-навчання але
є можливість звичайно якось себе
застосовувати в цьому ось
я думаю що ось один із таких варіантів
можна придумати тобто конкретно є
низка освітніх програм томілова
відкрила і jeunes space відкрили теж свої
безкоштовні курси тобто намагайтеся
утворюватися звичайно дуже складно тим
у кого немає знань англійської мови
тому що без мови в Європі принаймні
мірою досить складно я знаю наприклад і
англійська досконалість італійська
досконалості мені трошки простіше ось я
ризикую нас розумію що я можу вивчити
ще німецька та іспанська і тому що в
школі вчив німецькі іспанською тобто
потрібно звичайно вивчати мови тому що на
нею мов викриваючи зодяглися полегшує
комунікаційні всякі процеси в тому
числа вашого розвитку бізнесу ось тому в
Загалом я ж кажу тут енергія та допомога
потрібна
абсолютно підприємцям тому я
вважаю що та людина яка хоче
чогось добитися він шукає можливості той
хто нічого не може не хоче він шукає
виправдання ось тому точно не може не
вийде тому намагайтеся елементарно
навіть якщо
все погано точно фізично якась праця
вона завжди потрібна ось тому мені мені
звичайно дуже складно сказати зі своєю
вежі тому що в мене таки я 12
років відбудовувалася свій соціальний
капітал практично в кожній галузі у
мене є зв'язки підприємців і так
далі і саме моя експертність
вона цінується зокрема сьогодні
проводили вебінар з репарацій з
завданню прямих та непрямих збитків
бізнесу ми зараз відкрили також
напрямок, який досить популярний
це визначення вартості завданого
збитки компанії великим підприємством та
конкретно подання позовних заяв
проти країни-агресора ось тому це
напрямок ми зараз також підхоплюємо
ось тому тут я заговорю про до цього
2014 року це був перший сигнал після
якого треба було починати робити
домашнє завдання хто робив домашнє
завдання добре той принципі зараз я на
зараз розумієшся для
мене в цілому нічого не змінилося і ось
компанія в принципі працює на
повних потужностей є купа проектів і ми
завантажені ось для тих, звичайно то
домашнє завдання не виконала зараз
звичайно жахливий стрес та що що я бачу
повсюдно це те, що людей
закінчуються гроші на жаль ось це
це це сумно ну ось тому звичайно
зараз потрібно намагатися шукати
можливостей
формувати навколо себе природно
таке
співтовариство успішних підприємців
тому що ми є світити низьким від
нашого оточення і дуже важливо завжди
була навколо себе збирати та збирати
соціальний капітал це дуже важливо
тому і створюється бізнес-клубу для
того, щоб спілкуватися з собі подібними і
мультиплексування можливості
тому до речі кажучи бізнес-клубу це
дуже така дуже така важлива сильна
інструмент
який об'єднує успішних
підприємців
тому в цілому єдиного розумієте
єдиного єдиного єдиного еліксиру немає
кожен для себе знаходить еліксир
власне кажучи, виходячи зі своїх
можливостей
ось я мій елексир це бути максимально
активним сьогодні ось що місяць бинари
між вебінарами працюю ось і ніколи
не зупинятися на досягнутому
природно це якась внутрішня
потреба тобто заробити там що
тисяч доларів малих заробити мільйон
доларів мало треба йти йти вперед
вперед уперед тому що сьогодні може
здаватися що ти безпеки а
завтра якусь іншу країну прийде
знову війна тому важливо ще звичайно
думати наперед пару років
диверсифікувати активи вкладення
напрямі та капіталізувати себе
за допомогою розвитку в собі якихось
нових
навиків у тому числі інтелектуальних
навичок якоїсь експертності
уявіть ось що ви ходячи актив
який напханий або там ви ходяче тло
уявіть що ви iphone та iphone він
стає більше
функціональним після того, коли ви
закачуєте програму вважаєте що ви
iphone і ви себе закачуєте купу
додатків стає вас з'являються
нові можливості тому зараз якраз
таки час зараз переосмислити ні в
в якому разі не впадати у відчай
тому що енергія якщо ви дійсно
цього хочете тим більше їсти коли
чудової мотивації у вигляді коханої дружини та
дітей у вас просто немає вибору от
тому потрібно йти вперед і не
здаватися тому що рано чи пізно все
погане також як і хороше закінчується
тобто якщо зараз погано буде точно
добре якщо завтра добре точно прийде
якийсь момент стресу ось тому
важливо все це пам'ятайте заганяти
себе в штучний стрес щоб колись
прийде реальність ліс ви б і нічого не
дивувалися бо в мене.
ось так ну як що так і 200 розум режимі
pvp
можна викрутити зараз я в числі самих
троянди горілку заводі до інструментів том
числі онлайн-інструментів чайник 2 4
експертність друга можна випробувати все
багнет з знайти роботу в різьблених housings
скажімо так місяць був активістом і
фронті 3 c
[музика]
formula to навколо себе від дуже
оправлені до чоловіків до пункти дуже
важливо дуже важливо тому що якраз
таки ось дуже обидва але бідні нас з
середини там ще людиново нам і стати
у ньому модельне
модельне мислення
мобільним ісламі ніби вона врятує нас
Забезпечуючи вставляючи далі ми людьми і
колядина batch ще якось вибілені
люди на гарно на це вона починаючи
одиниця челендж ну крайня для мене і
я майже напасти і там розвивалися а
тому маєш важливі ось дуже себе ти
молитви та кіно на даний момент ви ще за
вас фінансово інтелектуально з до
допомагаючи більше ви до розвиватися вам теж
важливо його вдома. ти себе успішними
людьми а не для того, щоб не до вас
тягнулася ви ви не підписані та успішними
і якісь розвивалися топові небудь
іноді пекти посилальним стягуватися так так
стоїть сотки в шахті люди на віч тягну
нагороду та spur зникла так і я так сексу
логічно і навіть вам яскраву нас же
закінчується годину до купи один раз за
ваші паради і бажаю вам успіху в
розвитку бізнесу в уроці минулому минулому
навіть таке ми допоможемо слава українці
героям слава ви зодіаку і всім хто був з
нами великим якщо завтра 20 екзар де
муль но вич все добро поки